[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEFAN KUHNE: My
name is Stefan Kuhne.
I am one of the tech
leads bringing Chrome OS--
no, Android to Chrome OS.
Ha, very funny.
With me today is
Sara and Emilie.
And we are telling you a lot
about accessibility on Android
applications on Chromebooks.
So and with that,
well, you had that one.
First off, who of
you did any kind of
work bringing your applications
into the accessibility realm?
Did anyone?
Awesome.
Well you know what, you
are possibly already done.
But you don't have to leave now.
Please stay.
We have actually
some more things
which might be of
interest for you.
So and therefore
we have, hopefully,
some good tidbits for you.
So first of all, this
is one of the questions
for the rest of the folks.
Why should you care
about accessibility?
Well, it's a very
good question right?
Well within the US, for
example, one out of eight people
have a kind of a disability.
That is a shocking
big number, right?
So the thing is, like,
if you do not really
address this in
your applications,
you will actually miss
out on a lot of people.
Or look at it like
on a worldwide scale.
According to World
Health Organization,
there is 15% of people
which do not really--
well, which have some
kind of disability
and possibly some problems
with your applications
if you do not access that.
That is a big number.
So and then comes the
very interesting part
which nobody really
thinks about, that is
temporal disability.
That is something like what
everybody has every day.
When I am coming into
the office in the morning
and I am not really that awake
and I am looking at the screen
and the font is teeny
tiny, I will possibly
use a zoom in order to zoom
it up a little bit, which
is already an accessibility
feature in itself.
So and over the
course of the day,
I might actually revert
everything and make it actually
that the font is
getting smaller and I
get more information, which
is then maybe the reverse
if you want to say.
But the thing is, like, I'm
using that thing every day.
Or you are actually going
to a ski trip to Lake Tahoe,
and you broke a finger or
your wrist or anything else.
And, well, voila.
Try to use your keyboard.
Good luck.
There are problems which
everybody is facing once
in a while in your life.
Or look at this awesome event.
We have nice sunny
weather, except for now
when I'm looking outside.
But, well, it'll come
later today, again.
And then you're looking
at your screen outside.
You are trying to do something
on a notebook and you see
screen glare and you
cannot see anything.
So what do you do then?
Well, there is
actually a feature
which actually might
help you on that,
and you might actually
not be aware of it.
Coming to that one later.
And then there are other nice
features, like for example
the dictate feature, which
we heard already something
about in our keynote.
And things like this feature
is really totally awesome.
And I compare that
to 15 years ago.
I remember on a PC it was like
you had to train everything,
and it took a long time until
it finally understood you.
No problem at all.
I'm talking to that thing,
it transcribes everything.
And really, try it out.
It's awesome.
And/or do something
like, well, you
want to actually do
something while you're
working on something.
And well, you want to
read out, for example,
the latest article from
Maker News or something
like that while
you're doing this.
So it's another
accessibility feature,
because the thing is
at that point in time,
you're reading the screen.
So with that, let's go
into the features, what
we have on Chrome OS and
look at them one by one
what you have to do in order
to make these features happen.
And what we are, of
course, doing to do so.
Oh yeah, there
was another slide.
Look at that.
So we have actually
more form factors.
Well, you know, of course
a phone is this kind
of small device, right?
But we have a lot
of big devices.
So we have today coming
in all kinds of forms.
You have tablets.
You have convertibles,
clamshells.
And then there's
also boxes, which
means, like, you have really,
like, only an external screen
hooked up, which is of course
giant, which is awesome.
So make use of the space.
So and there are keyboards
and all these other things.
Chrome OS in a nutshell.
It's definitely much
more than only a phone.
So features.
So one other thing, the most
important feature, I think,
is this one, which
is ChromeVox, which
is, it reads out loud
what is on the screen.
It tells the user exactly what
is in a dialogue, in a window.
And it's actually guiding the
users through your dialogue.
And this is a very
important feature.
And if there is any
feature what you
have to really do
to your application
to make it accessible,
I think supporting
this one is really it.
Because things like this is
addressing 90% of the problems.
And that is essentially, like,
for every label you have--
no, for every screen element
you actually add another label,
which is giving you the talk.
What should actually
be talked of this way.
But Sara will actually
go more into depth later
on that in her talk.
So yes.
So next one.
Selector speech.
I was mentioning that already.
It's a great feature.
You can simply mark
something on the screen
and the screen
reader will actually
read everything to you aloud.
So what do you have to do in
order to support this thing?
Well, you should actually
have your text order
grouped in a certain way that
it's actually really readable.
But again, Sara will talk about
that one later in her talk
as well.
Another feature is
focus highlighting.
That is something like--
I mean, UI designers, they
are really very picky.
Everything needs to be exactly
the color as they specify them.
And sometimes that
is really very nice,
but not really very well
distinguishable for people
which cannot really see
these kind of things.
And sometimes, I
even have the problem
of actually seeing what is
really the focus or not.
And this feature, for
example, gives you
a much better visible focus
for all these kind of elements.
When you're typing in
something you see, for example,
a round circle
around your cursor
and so on, which makes it
much better visually so
that you can actually see this.
What do you have to do in
order to support this feature?
Well, basically everything
what you would always do.
Like for example, all the
UI elements you want to use
make them that they
are on the screen.
So don't move them out of the
screen only that they cannot be
visible or something.
Because when you're
Alt-Tab through them,
it might actually
come active, then you
don't even see what it is.
And/or you should also make
sure that the order of the items
is actually in the proper
order that you can actually
[? retab ?] through them.
Again, Sara Kato will actually
talk about that one later on.
So with that, we
have various features
in regards of how to
magnify the screen
to make it better visible.
The first one is the
docked zoom mode,
which is basically we are taking
apart one part of the screen.
And it's actually the
zoom, it's like a loop
where you can actually see then
what is underneath the cursor.
So this feature is very helpful.
You can even zoom
inside this area.
So you can select the zoom
factor you want to use.
So what do you have to do in
order to support this thing?
Well, your application
should be better resizeable
and/or at least re-layoutable
so that the content is actually
staying on the screen.
Another nice feature
is this one, which
is a full screen magnifier.
Basically the
desktop, everything
stays exactly as it is.
But there is only an
area of the screen
like this which is being shown
to the user on the full screen.
And then when you're
swiping with your mouse
over the screen,
you can actually
then reveal what is
hidden in the virtual area
of the desktop.
And what do you have
to do for this feature?
Nothing.
This is free off the house.
We are doing that for you.
I hope that helps.
Another thing is, well, we
have the full screen zoom
factor, which is
basically we are changing
the density on the fly.
So instead of seeing this
with a teeny tiny icon
size on the bottom, you
can make them much bigger.
And everything is
getting bigger,
which means bigger touch
targets, bigger screen, bigger
font, bigger everything.
Which means we are
changing the density.
What do you have to do in
order to support this feature?
Well, at the moment, you
should actually be resizeable,
and you should actually
listen to density changes.
So going forward,
you should definitely
check out if the density of
your application is changing
and react then accordingly.
So when you're using on
configuration changes,
make sure that you are
reading them accordingly.
So then there's a mouse.
The mouse is something many
people are simply like, hey,
where's my mouse.
Well, shake it a little bit.
Oh there it is, because you
can actually see the movement.
But the problem is if you cannot
really see even the movement
because the cursor
is still too small,
there's no way to
see that thing.
So therefore, we have
a special feature
where you can actually increase
the size of the mouse cursor.
What do we have to
do to support that?
Actually not very much.
In fact, nothing if you're
using the standard mouse cursor.
If you have a
separate mouse cursor,
however, you want to possibly
add multiple densities
for this particular resource.
Because otherwise
it might actually
look like the '80s,
with some kind
of very jaggy lines outside,
which looks interesting
but maybe not that nice.
So dictation feature.
Well, you simply click
into an input field.
You click on the button for
dictate, and you type away.
Well, talk away.
And what do you have to do in
order to support this feature?
Nothing.
Comes free of the house.
You're welcome.
It's awesome.
Another thing,
high contrast mode.
I was mentioning it already.
If you go outside,
sun glare and whatnot.
You can actually put the
screen into a special mode,
which is actually
improving the contrast.
What do we have to do
to support that thing?
Nothing.
We do everything for you.
You are done.
Well, then there are
many, many more features.
But the thing is for now
let's stay with that one.
And with that, I'm
passing it on to Sara.
SARA KATO: Great.
Thanks, Stefan.
So I'm Sara Kato.
I've come from Tokyo, and
I am a software engineer
working on accessibility
for Android applications
running on Chrome OS.
So you've just heard from Stefan
the importance of accessibility
as well as some other
accessibility features that
are available on Chrome OS.
What I want to do is to
talk to you developers
as to what you can do in
order to give the best
possible experience
for users who
are using accessibility features
to navigate with and interact
with your application.
With Chrome OS, users
are going to want
to use a keyboard as
a means of navigating
around the application
by moving focus.
And when you do
so, you need to be
aware of some of the subtle
details of how users are going
to interact with
your application,
and provide appropriate
feedback to users
based on their interactions.
You might know that since
Chrome OS has been launched,
it's been available in a number
of different form factors,
as Stefan just mentioned.
To provide some examples,
this includes the Samsung DeX,
Huawei desktop mode, Xiaomi,
Sony, LG, and the Pixel Slate
devices.
And I'm sure that you all own
probably more than one type
of laptop, more than
one type of phone.
And across these
different devices,
you expect your
applications to work.
And users who use
accessibility features also
expect the same experience.
And when the users use Android
applications on Chrome OS,
they need to be able
to accomplish actions
without the need
to rely on a mouse.
And you need to be
able to cater for this.
When users want to
use the keyboard
to interact with
your application,
they are probably going
to use the Tab key.
And with the screen reader
that Stefan just mentioned,
the Tab key is what allows
you to navigate linearly
using ChromeVox.
Users can also
choose to navigate
through a directional manner
that can move in the up, down,
left, and right direction.
And they can achieve
this using other controls
such as a directional pad,
also known as a D-pad.
And in both of these
cases, you need
to take note of when focus
does not get applied correctly.
Some other types
of input devices
that users may want to use
are trackpads or switch
for switch access.
And the types of users
who might be using these
are users with, say, mobility
issues or dexterity issues.
And they can find
an alternate means
to provide input and navigate
around your application.
So I've been talking a lot about
focus, but what exactly is it?
It's when the widget
is highlighted
to show a change of focus.
So you might be doing this
when you're navigating
a spreadsheet, for example.
When you're navigating
the spreadsheet,
you would often
use the arrow keys
to move between
adjacent cells, and you
would see that the cell
that you're currently at
is highlighted in blue.
And you can also do the same
in your Android application.
However, in your
Android application,
the order in which
focus is applied
is determined by the order
in which the elements appear
in the layout or the XML.
And if you find
that in this case,
linear navigation or even
directional navigation
doesn't work in the
way you expect it to,
then you'll need to
manually specify focus.
And this is what I
want to talk about now.
The examples that I'm
going to talk to you
about are going to
be in Kotlin, but you
should note that
you'll be able to do
the same using Java and XML.
And I want to show
you how in order
to make your application
more accessible,
you don't need excessive code
restructuring in addition
to what you've done already.
It's only a little
bit of extra code
that you need do to in order
to really help some users.
The first thing that
I want you to do
is to set your widget
to be focusable.
You can do this by setting the
setFocusable attribute to true.
Once you've done
that on your widget,
we can specify the behavior
for directional navigation.
And as I just mentioned,
this is for users
who might be using a
D-pad or a trackball.
And before this, the system
will provide a best guess
as to which viewer
should receive focus
based on the direction
of the layout
of the views of the screen.
But to specify the order, we can
use the setNextFocus attribute
and specify the
direction that should
receive focus and provide
the ID of the widget that
should receive focus.
And something that
I want you to note
is that if you fully support
directional navigation
in your application,
it's going to make
testing much easier because
it's going to give you
tools such as the UI
Automator, and you
will be able to automate
a lot of your UI testing.
I also talked about
linear navigation
using the Tab key for the
ChromeVox screen reader.
You can also specify
this behavior
using the setNextFocusForward
and specifying
the ID of the widget
in a similar manner.
I've talked a lot about
using the keyboard,
and we often use the keyboard as
a means of convenience as well.
For example, I'm sure that
you all use the Enter key.
You might use the Enter
key to submit forms
or to send messages.
And this is much easier than
clicking the submit button
or finding the correct
location on the screen.
And accessibility users
also expect the same.
They would expect the Enter
key to be able to provide them
with the same actions.
And you, as developers,
you can also
do this by setting
a key listener,
and I'm going to show you
how to add this behavior
to your application.
You first start by detecting
that a key was pressed down,
and you'll do this
using the ACTION_UP.
So this actually tells
you when you've actually
released the Enter key.
And since we're using ACTION_UP,
you might think, well,
is there an ACTION_DOWN event?
And there is.
And what is the difference
between these two?
Well, the ACTION_DOWN
returns multiple times.
And this can be
useful when you're
pressing the Enter key
for a long period of time,
for example.
Whereas the ACTION_UP
only returns once.
So maybe when you've
just held the key down,
like in this example.
Once we've detected that
we've indeed pressed the key,
we can go on to detect
that it was actually
the Enter key that was pressed.
And we can do this
by using the KeyEvent
and specifying that
we want the Enter key.
And you can change the
keyCode of the KeyEvent,
and I'll show you
how to do this later.
So I've talked about
using the keyboard
and how important it is
for Android applications
to be able to be
accessible by the keyboard
as they are able to
be run on Chrome OS.
And when you're adding
keyboard navigation,
you should remember that
accessibility users are going
to expect common keyboard
shortcuts, such as undo
and redo, to work.
So I'll show you
what you can do here.
A shortcut that you all
probably use everyday--
I mean, I know I use this every
day when I'm writing my code--
is the undo action.
This undo action,
the keyboard shortcut
is Control-Z. And let's take
a look at how we will do this.
So I just talked about how
you can use the keyCode.
And now in this example,
let's change the keyCode
to be Z because we're
looking for Control-Z.
Once we've done that, the
Control key is a special key
and we need to do something
that we call a meta state check.
And this also applies to
the Alt and the Shift keys.
So once we've done
that, we'll use
the hasModifiers function,
which returns true
once this is pressed.
And so now this example
gives us the ability
to detect the Control-Z action.
You can also combine
multiple hasModifiers.
So in this example,
we have the Control
and the Shift key pressed down.
So this allows us to detect
the Control-Alt-Z action, which
you might all know
as the redo action.
So another really important
concept is grouping.
Grouping is when related
content on your application
is organized into groups so
that accessibility services,
for example, a
screen reader, will
be able to announce the content
in a way which would reflect
its natural groupings.
This means that users
won't need to swipe,
scan, or wait in order to
find some other additional
information.
So let's think about who
these users might be.
These users might be
some blind people.
My blind friend, for example.
Or might be those with,
say, temporal impairments,
like Stefan mentioned.
Maybe you're driving
home from I/O today
and you really want to
use your application,
but you've got to keep
your eyes on the road
so we can't view the screen.
Maybe it's for my grandparents
whose vision is deteriorating,
and they need to
use a screen reader
to navigate an application.
So I want to show you an
example of what grouping might
be like in an application.
So I have an application
here for a grocery store
that I want to go to.
This application shows the
grocery item as well as
the prices.
And let's just see what
happens if we don't
specify any grouping at all.
The screen reader might read
out something like this.
Bread.
OJ.
$1.50.
$2.99.
As you've just heard,
after hearing the item
it takes a while before
we can hear the price.
But what might a
better example be?
A better example might
be the following.
Bread.
$1.50.
OJ.
$2.99.
You can immediately hear the
price of bread, which is $1.50,
after its announcement.
The same goes for OJ.
And this makes such
a big difference
for users who primarily
rely on the screen reader.
And you can do this with
the power of grouping.
For this, you would use the
android:screenReaderFocusable
attribute.
And this was introduced in
Android P and Android X,
and is preferred over the
android:focusable attribute,
which had some unwanted
effects in regards to focus
and navigation for users who
primarily relied on the screen
reader.
So in the previous example
for my grocery store,
you would group the item
as well as the price
into a single focusable
container, so that the screen
reader will be able to
present this information
into a single announcement and
show that these two items are
related to each other.
This means that users such as
you, such as my blind friend,
such as my grandparents,
will be able to understand
that these views are logically
related to one another.
Another important concept that I
want to talk about is labeling.
So labeling.
The purpose of
this is to explain
the meaning of interactive
elements to users.
I mean, I think you
often put labels
on physical items
in everyday life
just so you get a better
understanding of them.
This also makes
sense in the context
of an Android application.
By adding correct labels,
screen readers such as ChromeVox
will be able to properly explain
the function of the UI widgets
in your applications to users.
And I also think I can
demonstrate this better
with an example.
So I have an application here,
which is called Josie's Cafe.
This application allows you to
order items from Josie's Cafe.
And let's go and look at how
we structured this application.
So you can see that I've added
some image buttons as well
as the ID and the
source attribute.
Everything looks good, right?
So now let's go and see what
a screen reader might read.
So I have a friend.
His name is Reese.
Reese is low vision and relies
on the use of a screen reader
to navigate the application.
And Reese's favorite
food is pizza.
He really, really wants to
order pizza from Josie's Cafe,
so he turns on his screen reader
and opens the application.
What does he hear immediately?
He hears button.
Hm.
Let's see if there's
anything else available.
So Reese presses Tab.
He hears button.
Hm.
OK.
One last time.
I'm going to press Tab again
to see what else I can get.
Presses Tab again.
Button.
Hm.
As you can see, this
type of navigation
doesn't really support
users such as Reese
to navigate the application.
But it's really easy
for you to change this.
And let's look at how
we'll do that using labels.
So I have some image buttons.
So we're going to use the
content description tag.
And you can see here that for
these content description tags
I've added the actual item that
the image button represents.
And the actual attributes
that you might use
would depend on the type
of element that you have.
But once I've added all
my content descriptions,
let's just see what the screen
reader would now read to Reese.
So Reese decides to
give it one last shot
and opens the application again.
He immediately hears chocolate.
OK.
Not really in the mood
for chocolate now.
Let's see what else is
available in Josie's Cafe.
Eeew.
OK, let's just hope that he
doesn't end up with this.
Pizza.
Awesome.
Reese is now able to
order his favorite pizza
from Josie's Cafe.
As you can see, just by
adding content descriptions
made such a big difference
to users such as Reese.
So I've talked about
some simple views,
but if you have some more
complicated or custom views
in your application, you might
need some additional work
in order to make
it more accessible.
And the Android
Developer documentation
has more detail on
the specific tasks
that you might need to do.
So with that, I'll hand over
to my colleague, Emilie.
EMILIE ROBERTS: Thanks, Sarah.
My name's Emilie Roberts,
and I'm a developer advocate
with Chrome OS.
And-- what's my
next line, I forget?
OK.
There we go.
We've been talking a lot
about input and keyboard.
And I think fundamentally
what this talk is really about
is how users interact with and
experience your applications.
And we're going to
talk a little bit--
I'm going to talk a little
bit about screens and layout,
which is near and
dear to my heart.
And doing this right,
doing all of this right,
can be the difference
between a user
not being able to
use your app at all
or at least being
able to use it.
For it to be convenient to use
or to be inconvenient to use.
And I think where
we all want to get
is for your users to find
your app delightful to use,
natural to use.
So whatever the service or
content they want is just,
that's the choice for your app.
And I think that
applies for all users,
and for accessibility
users that's magnified.
So I see some familiar
faces, some Chrome OS fans.
And I've talked about some of
this stuff in my last talk.
This is the dress I wear when I
talk about screens and layouts,
so that's why it's
the same dress.
If you ever see this dress,
you can skip the talk.
No, just kidding.
We have some really
great sandboxes around,
so if you haven't seen your app
on a Chrome OS device check it
out.
And see if which
category-- hopefully you're
not in the unusable category
for accessibility folks,
but hopefully you're in
the delightful and easy and
natural.
And that's where we want to go.
So we're in an era
of changing screens.
We heard that in the
keynote announcement
and in many of the sandboxes.
There's phones, tablets,
Chromebooks, external monitors,
foldables, you name it.
And who knows what's coming
out this year and next year?
The app world is
changing, and you really
want your apps to
just work seamlessly
across all of these devices.
In a big way--
oh wait, I got to
tell you my story.
I wrote this on the side.
So I want to talk about
my mom because I bought
her a Pixelbook, and there's
so many Android apps she would
never think of using her phone.
And my mom has pretty good
vision-- she's very able--
and just having it
on a larger screen
makes it so much more delightful
and easier to engage with.
And for many
accessibility users,
using an external monitor
can be life-changing
or using a-- not life-changing,
but completely enabling.
And using a screen reader can
mean your app can be used.
Cool.
So for many applications, this
is about layout and screen
size.
And the easiest way to do
this, or a really great way,
in my opinion, to do this is to
have different layout buckets
for different screen sizes.
In this case, I'm using width.
So for a large landscape
or a large portrait,
I might have a different
layout versus a mobile phone
portrait or landscape.
You can have six, eight,
two layouts depending
on what your UI looks like.
In the Codelab tent, we
have a resizing codelab
which can help you with this.
My focus on my
team this year has
been looking at navigation
patterns for large screens,
especially as we see
foldable devices and more
external monitors happening.
And of course the growing
range of Chromebooks.
And they're very closely
related to screen layout,
but I think it deserves
its own separate topic.
So imagine you have a mobile
phone application designed
for narrow portrait screens, and
you plug in an external monitor
to see what that looks like.
And it looks horrible.
It looks terrible, and the
designer should go back
to design school.
I'm recycling my
joke from yesterday.
So throw her out of the room.
She's horrible.
Look at that
stretched out screen.
This is a photo
viewer, by the way.
So maybe on a phone
it makes sense
if you have 100
photos not to try
to show 100 previews
on a phone screen,
but on an external
monitor, come on.
We can do better than that.
And what I think is
specifically important
for many users with
accessibility needs
is the navigation.
Along the bottom, here
is the bottom navigation.
It's all stretched out.
The icons are tiny, and they're
just in this vast sea of space.
So even if your eagle eyed
and have excellent dexterity,
it's very difficult to see,
to understand, and to interact
with these elements.
And you can imagine
it being literally
impossible for some people.
OK.
I was the designer.
Give me a second chance.
I did a better job.
I even included a photo
preview on the side
and made a little bit better
use of the screen real estate.
This is like moving
in the direction
of making my app easy and
delightful, convenient to use.
I've done a little bit
better in the middle column.
And most importantly,
take a look
at the navigation on the left.
Side navigation.
There's labels.
There's icons.
They're visible.
And they're all grouped nicely
together so I can easily
go from one to the
other without having
to search around on the screen.
Oh, I've got to go back.
This, live, about
30 minutes ago.
This beautiful, amazing
photo viewing sample
is available on GitHub
for your perusal.
It's just a little demo.
It's not that amazing,
but check it out.
Okey dokey.
More information is available
on the material design site.
They have a number of material
studies, a number of case
studies that you can look at.
This is the reply app, and
they're doing just this.
So four different layouts
depending on the screen
size you're looking at.
In the first example with
the long stretched out bottom
navigation, the targets were
very small, hard to see,
and hard to interact with,
especially for someone
with any dexterity needs.
We recommend a minimum
touch target size of 48dp.
That's not new.
Hopefully you all
know that, but it's
super important for all the
reasons I've just outlined.
You can also use
ConstraintLayout
and allow it to scale up
naturally using percentages
and make it easier to squish
those little pink aliens.
Here's just a quick example.
A little bit exaggerated, but
on a portrait mobile phone,
why not have the
icons visible and easy
to interact with and clear.
I don't have a lot of
time left, but I just
want to give a big shout-out
to ViewModel and Navigation
and Jetpack as a whole, if
you haven't been using it.
Check out their sandbox,
and the codelabs,
and their talks and
the documentation.
It's awesome.
As an Android developer, my main
pain points have just, like,
disappeared with it.
When you're handling
different screen layouts,
ViewModel makes state so elegant
and easy to just maintain.
You don't have to worry about if
you're resizing on a Chrome OS
app and you're getting
20 configuration changes.
This is real, and
it goes up and down.
It can be 100
configuration changes.
It's hard to handle
all by yourself,
but if you use ViewModel,
done, finished.
Finished.
Navigation.
If you're working with all those
different navigation patterns,
fragments can be a headache.
Popping the stack and
if you have a fragment
in a fragment in a fragment.
If you know what I'm talking
about, it's super hard.
Navigation makes that a lot
easy. d.android.com/jetpack,
check it out.
I'm going to take the
last couple of seconds
just to call out something
that's unique to Chromeboxes,
espec--
or, Chromebooks.
Let me say it again.
It's not necessarily
unique to Chrome OS,
because lots of
phones these days
are supporting desktop mode.
So it's in the Android Q APIs.
Huawei, Samsung, LG, I believe
all have desktop modes.
Plugging external monitors
into your Android devices.
On Chrome OS, this is even
easier and much more common.
And with Chromeboxes-- sorry,
I should say with Chromeboxes--
it's required.
There's no other screen.
So we can have up to
seven external monitors.
For the most part, you
don't have to do anything.
Your apps will just work and
the users can move them around.
If you check out the live--
or sorry, the recorded
version of our talk, Stefan
went into a bit more detail
about how density works.
But if you just want to do
something with your activities,
you can get a look at
the number of displays
connected to your system
using the display manager.
And then if you want
an activity to appear
on a specific display, you can
use launchDisplayID and pop it
over there.
OK, couple last mentions.
We have a couple of codelabs.
One is on resizing.
One is on optimizing input
for Chrome OS devices.
So that's keyboard,
mouse, drag and drop.
All that great stuff.
These have been
refreshed for 2019.
Accessibility has
their own codelab,
which goes a lot
more into detail
with grouping and labeling.
And this has also had a
nice refresh for 2019.
So check that out in
the Codelab tents.
As I mentioned, there
are some great sandboxes.
The accessibility and material
design sandbox is over there.
It's close by, so check that
out as well as our Chrome OS
sandboxes where you can try out
first of all your applications
and see where you fall on the
scale of unusable, convenient,
and amazing.
Hopefully towards the A
side, the amazing side.
And you can also look at
developing your apps right
on Chromebooks
for web, for game,
for Android, which
is also pretty cool.
And don't forget
while you're there
to collect your really
cool Chrome OS enamel pins.
We have seven of them with
the secret eighth one,
which I don't know if
I'm supposed to mention.
But collect them around
at the Android sandbox,
at the Chrome OS sandbox, at
the gaming sandbox, Codelabs,
and our office hours.
With that, it's about
time to say goodbye.
I think accessibility
matters and you
should implement it because it's
the right thing to do, period.
At the same time,
it enables all users
for all the cases we've
been talking about,
including yourself.
It makes your app much,
much more easier to use,
much more delightful to engage
with, better to engage with.
So you have more
users, more enabled,
more users more happy
users, more empowered users.
And that's the sum of my talk.
I want to say if you take three
things away from this support
keyboard, think about your
layouts and navigation,
and most importantly add labels
and grouping to your app.
Adding labels and grouping
can go a really long way
to enable OSs to then
do intelligent things
with your apps and make
them available to lots
and lots of users.
So I'd like to thank you
for your time this morning.
And building awesome
apps, thinking
about Chrome OS, and all this
stuff and your energy here.
And also to thank Sara and
Stefan, my fellow copresenters.
Have a wonderful last
day of I/O. Enjoy it.
Thanks a lot.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]